Because so many of you Fellow Scholars have
requested it, today we are going to look at
one of the best papers of the year.
An incredible work that I really hope
will revolutionize the creation of virtual
worlds for movies and video games, and more.
Just imagine grabbing your smartphone, taking
a few images or videos of real-world places,
and then, we could create a virtual version
of them and play in them in real time. That
would be amazing. Just imagine that we could
drive on the streets of San Francisco and LA,
go on a virtual hike and see what it would look
like, and a ton of other, really cool things.
Techniques that involve rendering radiance
fields, for instance, NERFs have this as a goal,
and a ton of them already exist. But,
with those, we have two huge problems.
One, they are not fast enough. For huge
scenes in full HD or higher resolution,
getting a real time solution is tough.
It typically goes slower than that.
And two, of course thin structures, it’s always
the thin structures that are a problem. Now,
these are quite plentiful in scenes in the
real world. Plant leaves, cables, fences,
bicycle spokes, that kind of thing. All thin
structures. Yes, all of those are problems.
Now I see big words here, because this new
technique promises results more than 10
times faster in terms of rendering time than
NVIDIA’s excellent Instant NERF technique,
so of course, the quality
has got to be lower, right?
Wait a second. Look here. Are you
seeing what I am seeing? The thin
structures indicate that this is not only
more than 10 times faster in rendering time,
but it also promises higher quality
results than the previous methods. Wow!
And upon further inspection…
this is so much cleaner,
so much better. And it is ridiculous
how much better it is in quality
than some of the other, quite capable
previous methods from just a year ago!
And yes, that’s right. Now we can get
a virtual copy of the real world with
difficult thin structures
going in full HD and yes,
real time. Much, much faster than
than real time. My goodness, so good!
And here comes the punchline. Hold on to
your papers, because we should likely not
call this technique a NERF variant, because
this does not use neural networks. Yes,
this is a good old handcrafted
computer graphics technique. Wow.
So how does all this wizardry work? We take
out the super capable neural networks, and
replace them with a little human ingenuity, and
it gets better? How? Well, this has two key ideas.
Now, we have a 3D world at hand which has to be
represented on our 2D screen. Now the Gaussian
part means that objects in this scene will
be represented as a sum of many little lumps.
It is a bit like throwing a small pebble into
water. The pebble might be a small little point,
but the waves it creates spread out around this
point. Sounds good, right? Well, not so fast.
Unfortunately, in the 3D space, many of these
waves overlap and it is unclear how exactly
they can be transferred onto our 2D screens. And
splatting is a way of throwing these little waves
from the 3D virtual world at our 2D screen and
computing what they should really look like. As
an additional advantage, these waves concentrate
around solid objects, and thus, this technique
does not have to waste time computing parts of
the scene with lots of empty space. Loving it!
Idea number two, typically NERF algorithms
are interested in going through every single
pixel on your screen, and instead, this one is
interested not in pixels, but in the primitives,
objects in the scene. Now, the concept is not new,
it has been used in computer graphics for decades,
but how it is applied to this problem
is the cool and interesting part.
All in all, this is a simple
algorithm, it is really fast,
and we don’t have to sacrifice
quality. I mean, look at that!
I would like to send huge
congratulations to the entire team,
and to the shared first author Bernhard who
is my former colleague and a good friend.
Now, not even this technique is perfect, for
instance, rendering specular reflections is
not perfect. These light transport
effects look much more crisp in the
real world. This first unoptimized version
also consumes quite a bit of memory. However,
just imagine what we will be capable of just
one more paper down the line. I am a computer
graphics researcher by trade, I specialize in
light transport, ray tracing if you will, and
I am always so happy to see a good
graphics paper rip. And this one,
this one is something different. Also, it just
came out a few days ago, and look how it already
captured the imagination of some Fellow
Scholars there. What a time to be alive!
If you enjoyed this episode and would
like to see many more amazing papers,
consider subscribing to the
channel and hitting the bell icon.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!